I guess living in India wasn't risky
enough a lot of flip-flops
let's go Tom's get these kids some of
your cheap-ass shoes already maybe throw
in a helmet do people really need noses
and lips that's what you get for playing
hooky from the call center jumping eight
kids in India is like only two and a
half in America with the current obesity
exchange rate try jumping eight people
with an illegal alien on your handlebars
you got one one that's hanging tea you
make me look like an idiot et I've had
it up to here with the e-team tomorrow
I'm turning him over to the government
for medical testing
[Applause]
[Music]
I bet he was texting now let's watch the
only race in Utah
besides Caucasian and this week's
breakdown welcome to the Tour de Utah
it's like France if fun were illegal now
drive a little bail on my handlebars and
you ruined his suicide or blocked him
from taking an amazing shortcut all
those crappy crossover vehicles and you
just had to crash into $100,000 Porsche
Panamera
where's Lance's clean blood truck when
you need it yeah they must not have
accounted for the fact that their legs
are freshly shaven smart move for that
motorcycle slip out while everyone's
focus on saving those people's lives
I had a disaster on a bike ones where I
couldn't get my spin shoes on clipped
better slow down there's a race to win
first place gets assigned David
Archuleta CD we are in Mormon land so
this might just be one family going on a
bike ride and for that we thank you
technically this next guy has as many
Tour de France titles as Lance Armstrong
that guy is huge
yet they'll still find a way to take up
a whole lane he also has the world's
tiniest case of testicular cancer do you
know I have it even smaller bicycle and
it's built for two where was the bike
did you see it I didn't see it this show
isn't even trying anymore
let's find out why you never try to
out-grand the canyon you see what you're
forcing us to do black people you've
just shoved us out of normal sports
and now we're jumping off mountains
by the way you get extra points if you
go farther than your bike I've got a
scream sound of majestic echoing off the
canyon walls
[Music]
[Applause]
never cheer until there's a safe landing
because now you all look stupid there's
no shame in bailing out when things get
dangerous I do it all the time so what
do you do I haven't booked anything yet
but I'm an actress
and that's why I always wear a helmet
cam on the first date
you